luke pollard has been the labour mp for
plymouth sutton and devonport since 2017
joins us now we spoke just yesterday on
the program mr pollard under very
different circumstances who could have
thought just a few hours later this
would unfold on your streets
absolutely i mean kim is a
uh is normally a safe part of our city
it's a strong knit community where you
know your neighbors and you look out for
one another and to
hear the news that there is a shooting
taking place in our communities
is awful but to then
hear from local residents
and the police that that has resulted in
deaths and we understand that five
people have been killed and the shooter
is now dead as well
is just utterly devastating um and we
will sadly
hear more grim news today i think when
the police start issuing
information about their sense of
timeline of events about what happened
where and when
who the shooter was but most importantly
is who the victims are
and to understand
what happened
in the events yesterday but this is a
awful tragedy probably the darkest day
in plymouth history since the end of the
second world war in terms of the number
of casualties all at the same time it
really is horrendous here have you been
given any insight by the police as to
what happened
so the police are still trying to piece
together uh the timeline of events um uh
to get a full understanding of it but we
understand that from six o'clock last
night the shooting began on biddick
drive which is a quiet residential
cul-de-sac in kiem area the police have
cordoned off quite a large area
here because we understand that it's not
just in this particular street where
activities took place but i'm hoping
that the police will be able to share
more of that information later today
when they make a statement to the media
there's lots of people in our community
here who are
looking for an explanation looking for
anything to try and explain how such a
horrific event can happen on our streets
and i'm hoping that the police will be
able to come forward with a bit of that
information uh later today
um you said i think last night that one
of the victims was under the age of 10
and we are also hearing that one of the
victim one of the people dead is the
gunman is is that your understanding
yeah so um in the immediate aftermath i
spoke with an awful lot of local
residents in the area who are very
concerned about what was happening
to try and get a sense of it the police
are still trying to piece together all
the details uh about what's happened uh
and what happened to the shooter uh
beforehand uh but we understand that uh
that the uh uh that
the number of people died is is five
that were shot we're trying to
understand exactly what happened to the
shooter at the end of this incident
but i'm expecting i'm afraid uh
particularly grim news
about one of the victims and i think for
a lot of people the idea of a shooting
is horrendous enough but potentially the
shooting involving children
is something that is uh
that's really bad yeah incomprehensible
isn't it um
talk to me about local residents there
because they are you know they've got
this police do not cross line around
them acquire parts of your constituency
could never have imagined that something
like this would happen just after tea
time last night um how are they coping
and and
what what support can you give them
i think the overwhelming emotion here is
shock and then devastation as to as to
the news
for lots of local residents that were
immediately in the area
opening the door to see something
horrendous happening literally in front
of them in their community is is
especially uh painful and it will take a
lot for that community to be able to
process and understand and heal together
i'm really glad that our local primary
school at ford primary school and the
local churches in the area have agreed
to open they'll be opening from 9am
today to provide a space for uh the
community to to come together and after
the year that we've all had we know the
value of human contact but just the
space to be able to
talk to one another just to kind of talk
through what has happened and why
something like this and how something
like this could have happened in our
community i think is especially valuable
but you know i want to say a big thank
you to our emergency services for being
so speedy on the scene here it wasn't
just the police and the ambulance crews
that sped to the scene we had
not only our local air ambulance but air
ambulances from across the entire
southwest region and further afield as
well supporting the operation so it
really was an exceptional effort but now
we need to make sure that as a community
we're pulling together that we're
looking after one another that we are
taking time to
listen and to
understand and then to heal but i'm
afraid that we're expecting the grim
news to continue today as we understand
how many people have been injured and
who the victims are do you have any idea
when the police are likely to update us
i'm hoping that there will be a a a
statement from the police uh later this
morning from the chief constable to give
an update on on where the police
investigation is up to to set out what
they know uh has taken place there's in
the community as tight-knit as this
there's there's clearly a lot of people
uh being able to share their impressions
but i think what's important here is
that we get that the facts from the
police as they understand them and that
if there are people who um have
information to be able to share that
with the police to help them piece
together that entire timeline of events
and then
we need to make sure that uh that
everyone involved be it the victims
those people who are injured the
families of the victims or a wider
community here
have the space to make sure that they
can come together and we've got victim
support available all day here in
plymouth for those people that have been
affected but this is uh something that
doesn't happen in our city plymouth is a
wonderfully safe city normally it's
known for
things that aren't uh shootings that
aren't that high level crime and i think
that shock of the events that take place
will be
uh will take time for our community to
to be able to process and to be able to
heal but um we'd start that today kim is
certainly a community with a lot of
heart and my words that we need that
today